I was in New York this weekend for the
massive failure the Furious premiere the
movie is electric and we have four fast
facts about the film starting with the
rumored onset feud between Dwayne
Johnson and Vin Diesel was it real you
guys seem to view inventive seem to work
out whatever was gone tell me about it
and what is it where does it stand now
yeah well because at the end of the day
the most important thing is making a
movie right oftentimes just like in life
you have different philosophies and
people have different philosophies
different fundamental philosophies on
how you do things and again the most
important thing is just the movie so I'm
happy that we're here in New York City
I'm happy that the fans love it
I'm happy that in the movie I'm um
what's that thing Oh amazing we still
love each other that's my boy when I was
making that difficult decision should
there be a gate or not I called him he
said brother I will be there
shoulder-to-shoulder with you to make
sure it's the best movie in history fast
fact number two it's the first film in
the franchise shot since the death of
actor Paul Walker Scott Eastwood joins
the team not that you replace Paul but
in a sense coming in and joining this
team after Paul what was that like in
DINO replacing Paul ever ever ever ever
Paul was a good friend to all of us this
is his family and you know what better
way to continue his legacy did you get
hazed a little bit by these guys always
first thought they called me little
nobody I don't even know if that was in
the script haha they came up with that
and it snuck in the movie fast fact
number three Tyrese told me how he
pulled off that secret Valentine's Day
wedding to his girlfriend Samantha Lee
he told friends no phones no tweets no
instagrams she happened to have and I
have an absent people in my life that
was able to respect the request that's
all it took it was the first red carpet
ever for Tyrese's new wife fast fact
number four details on those dreadlocks
Charlize told me that was a heavy wig I
won't
there was such craftsmanship behind it
that I just had such appreciation for it
but at the end of the day when we took
it off it felt like 20 pounds have been
removed off my head
Charlize is a fantastic villain in the
movie
[Music]